nous en parlions déjà hier le tribunal
de commerce de tours a décidé de placer
le tours fc en redressement judiciaire
pour une période de six mois
un énième rebondissement dans l'histoire
du club de foot
alors quel est l'avenir de la société
coopérative qui vient d'être créé pour
permettre à de petits actionnaires
d'investir dans leur club de coeur
va-t-elle servir à renflouer les caisses
du club déficitaire on fait le point
avec lucas chopin les difficultés
continuent pour le tours fc
à la demande des dirigeants le tribunal
de commerce de tours a placé le club en
redressement judiciaire
une situation liée à la dette du tfc qui
s'élèverait à près de 2 millions d'euros
pourtant pour se relancer le tours
football club a lancé il ya deux mois un
projet de sci c'est une entreprise
coopérative dans laquelle chacun peut
investir mais bien que mise en pause
pour quelque temps le projet est loin
d'être abandonné
il est tout à fait imaginable que l'on
puisse envisager de rendre cette
structure là avec la cie qui
deviendraient actionnaires
ainsi bâle 6 ou considère que c'est aux
mauvaise des solutions de ce que je
connais et je suis raisonnablement
optimiste même si je sais que on n'est
qu'à la moitié du chemin quoi de
nombreux particuliers et collectivités
se sont d'ores et déjà engagés à
investir dans la cei c'est une fois
créés c'est notamment le cas de la ville
de tours mais la mairie là sur son
argent ne sera pas engagée dans le
remboursement de la dette
il faut rassurer les courants gêné pour
en jour aujourd'hui ce ne sont que des
promesses de participation à hauteur de
50 euros minimum et en aucun cas ses
promesses de participation où la
participation des collectivités ne
viendrait pour assainir la dette au delà
des difficultés économiques le
redressement judiciaire du tfc pourrait
avoir de lourdes conséquences sur le
plan sportif
le tours football club s'expose
désormais à une relégation forcée de
deux divisions